Allah sizi şimdi Türkiye gibi yapacağız
Duygu durumundan Duygu durumuna hayat
bayram olsun dan sonra aslında Çok
tatsız bir konudan bahsedeceğim takdir
edersiniz ki bu tür organizasyonlarda
Türkiye'de önceden konu bilerek o kadar
kolay olmuyor çünkü bir anda bir şey
oluyor ülke gündemine bomba düşüyor iki
gün önce olduğu gibi bi herhalde
dünyanın en trajik bölümlerinden biridir
değil mi Bir anne bir kadın 10 yaşındaki
kızının önünde Üstelik Yeşilçam dram
larında bile bir senaristin yazamayacağı
bir senaryo gibi birşey lütfen ölme anne
diyor ama son sözü de ölmek istemiyorum
oluyor gerçekten ölümün her bir ölüm
trajik Beklenmeyen ürünler daha trajik
Ama bu herhalde milyonda bir olacak bir
şey Ben zaman zaman alıntılar dım
bir şeyler yaşadığımızda Ben sadece bir
yazar olarak gibi düşünce adam olarak da
çok sevdim Nurlar içerisinde yatsın
Yaşar Kemal'in şimdi daha çok duyduğumuz
bir sözü vardı ve Türkiye ilişkin bir
şey söylüyor ne diyor Türkiye'de dört
şey olmayacaksın diyor kadın-çocuk ağaç
ve sahipsiz hayvan Sokak hayvanı
Sonrasında da Maalesef ki şöyle bir
cümle ile bitiriyorum Umarım diyor öbür
dünyada diyor Türkiye yoktur diyor
Evet Ee biz batının bu kadar çok seven
insanların buna bazı zamanlarda inanması
Bence korkunç bir şey Peki ne olacak
bundan sonra Diye sorduğumuzda Aslında
bu sene Biz biliyoruz söyle olacak Biz
ter ya da Figen'e devam edeceğiz sosyal
medya yazacağız tepkiler adlı Selim
olarak düşündüğümüz insanlar idamdan
bahsedecek kastrasyon dan bahsedecek
şiddet duygularımız tırmanacak Aslında
şiddetle şiddeti çekeceğiz sonra Tüccar
siyasiler
bu işte ilk önce Muhalefet partileri
diyecek ki biz bununla ilgili yasayı
meclise sunduğu diyecek etkilerden bir
sesle gelmeyecek ve bir sonraki bak aya
kadar biz bu konuyu unutacağız bir
sonraki tepkiye kadar hatırlarsanız
geçen hafta aslında başka bir gündemle
Türkiye sarsıldı Trend topic oldu Neydi
çok meşhur bir kadın oyuncumuz şişte
doğumdan sonra aldığı yoğun kilolarla
konu olduğu magazin basını üzerine
atladığı önce sonra yaptın ağzı
kullandırma daha çok direkt Açıktan da
yazanlar vardı Bu arada bence güzel
hareketler pek çok mesajla karşılaştık
belki binlerce onbinlerce mesaj söz
konusu kadın önünde Sen her halinle
güzelsin ama anne olarak daha güzelsin
dedi
Evet Ee bu gönlümde iyi gibi görünmesine
rağmen ben hep söylerim şeytanım katlı
en çok kendim için yaparım döndüm ve
mesajları teker teker bizim sosyal
bilimlerde içeriklerimiz dediğim
yöntemle saymaya başladım etiketlenmiş
15l girme Ağustos arasında tam 16500
mesaj Saydım 16500 mesaj arasında hemen
hepsine kadar güzel olduğunu ve
oyuncumuzu destekleyici mesajlar atarken
121 kişi başka bir şey soruyordu 121
kişi şunu soruyordu Peki diyordu İyi de
güzel de biz de katılıyoruz annelik bir
kadının belki en güzel hali duygusal
olarak en azından ama
Oh buz bahsettiğimiz hastalıklı marazzi
ekosistemin oluşturucu larından biri de
siz değil misiniz oynadığınız reklam
filmleriyle marka yüzü olduğunuz moda
markasıyla dizilerin izle ya da sosyal
medya sürekli paylaştığı fotoğraflarla
kadın dedenin kadına ilişkin
yüklediğimiz bütün güzellik algılarını
oluşturucu larından biri siz değil
misiniz diye soruyordu Bu çok iyi bir
soru buradaki Sorun ne biliyor musunuz
bu kadar az sayıda insanın bunu sormaz
sadece 121 kişi bunu soruyordu çok
duyusuz eğitim programlarına zaman zaman
ben de televizyonda konuşurken dilimize
pelesenk oldu 21 Siz yetenek ve
becerileri diyoruz değil mi İşte bir
Sırada ne var diyalektik olmak var yani
bir şeyi test sentez halinde durağında
düşünmek yani karşıtıyla düşünmek geldi
muhakeme etmek ya da al ettik olmak ne
kadar az lan elitis ne kadar az
sorguluyoruz farkında mısınız çok az 121
kişinin sorması bunu Yani insanlar genel
Tabii ki beyin dilimdesin evinde Biz
bana müzik Deniz kısayollar oluşturun ve
hızlıca şöyle davranırız versiyonlarını
söyle olur taraftar çekmek için Grup
oluşturmak için ve sürü psikoloji
çerçevesinde doğru yapmak için hızlıca
destek mesajları veririz ve arkasını çok
fazla sorgulamanız aklıma satırın O çok
güzel sözünü getiriyor toplum diyor
İflah olmaz bir hastalıktır diyor bu
sözü Ben kafamda belki Semerkant kitabın
hepiniz okumuşsunuzdur diye düşünen
Lübnanlı yazar alayım marufun çok güzel
bir sözüyle tamamlıyorum bizimde
kıyısında dolaştığımız Ortadoğu insan
için şunu söylüyor her zaman her şeye
hep ve çok çabuk kızan Ama hiçbir şey
yapmayan insanlar topluyor Orta Doğu
insanı tanımlarken gerçekten hiçbir şey
yapmıyoruz STK larda çalışmıyoruz
örgütlü toplum olamıyoruz Ondan sonra
sadece şikayet ediyoruz siyasetten
şikayet ediyoruz toplumsal vakalardan
şikayet ediyoruz ve bir sonrakine
Bekliyoruz bakalım
e Devlet derim görünen her şey aslında
görünmeyenden kaynaklanır iki tane
olgudan bahsedeceğim size ulusal
televizyonlarda en çok karşımıza çıkan
oldu bir tanesi reklamlar bir tanesi
televizyon dizileri çokça izlediğiniz
biz iki özel Araştırmadan kendi
Araştırmadan bahsedeceğim bir tanesi
reklamlardaki kadın bedeni temsil ile
ilgili Reklamın dili kitabında da yazdım
bunu 4 aylık dergi toplam 379 reklamda
sıraladım içerik analizi olarak tematik
bir kategori altında Biz reklamlarda
kadını kadınlık rollerine nasıl temsil
ediyoruz bedenin nasıl temsil ediyoruz
nasıl görüyoruz diye baktım Reklamcılık
deyip geçmeyin Batı odaklı kaprisli
toplumdaki biz öyle bir toplumuz günde
Yaklaşık 3 bin reklam mesajına maruz
kalırız dolayısıyla çok önemli anlamış
üzerinden bahsediyoruz yirmi iki tane
kategori çıktı arkadaşlar 22 kategorinin
bazılarını size sayayım
bu soyunan kadın dedeni kadınların
doğrudan cinsel obje olarak gösterimi
kadınların parça parça beden
unsurlarıyla cinsel obje olarak
gösterimi aşağılanan kadın bedeni fetiş
leştir ilmiş kadın bedeni kadının Aile
içerisinde gösterimi kadının kentle
birlikte gösterimi masquerain kadın
bedeni ve Rus vesaire gibi kozmetikte
birlikte kadının gösterimi böyle giden
bir sıralama var böyle bir toplumsal
Cinsiyet gösteriminden ne olmasını
bekliyorsun sorusunun cevabı ise kadına
dair bütün bu şiddet ve benzeri
olayların çıkması son derece anlamlı
geliyor bana sadece burada kalmadım tabi
kısa kısa anlatıyorum araştırmaları
2016/18 yılları arasındaki o çokça
izlediğimiz televizyon dizilerinde
biliyorsunuz Belki televizyon en önemli
iki musluğu bizim için televizyon
dizileri Türk dizileri ve aynı zamanda
yarışma programları biraz oraya bakalım
dedim ve oradaki kadınlık t
en ideal kadın bedenini erkeğin rolü
çocuğun pozisyonunu anlamaya çalıştım
burada ortaya çıkan sonuçları şöyle
sıralayabilirim eğer biz kadını ideal
fiziksel cinsel obje olarak sıralıyor
Sak tanıyorsa ki çok şey yapıyoruz
özellikle başrolü Başar troller de şunu
yapıyoruz kadınlar kentli çoğunlukla çok
bakımlar Bunlar cinsel obje olarak
sunulan kadınlar 175 dakika bizi çeken
teknik olduğumuz için ondan sonra 13
şoförlükle iniyoruz uzun uzun Kadraj
larla hiç bitmeyen bacaklar görüyoruz
mesela arpleks son olarak özel
tasarımlar kıyafetler özel tasarım
İtalyan tanesi televizyonculuk anlayışı
vardır ya güzel kadını herkes görmek
ister kadınlar zaten görmek ister
erkeklerde güzel kadın görmek ister
mantıyla reytingi buradan almaya
çalışıyoruz Şimdi bunu be tırnak
söylüyorum bunu bakımsız kadınların
arkadaşlar üreme şansı bile yok
Bu normal dizilerde herhangi bir şekilde
bir romantik ilişki içerisinde ya da
karşı ise herhangi bir aksiyonlu
görmüyoruz böyle bir şey yok engelli
kadın temsili diye bir şey geç yok Bu
arada kadınları etnik kimliklerine göre
de sınıflandırıyoruz mesela kentli kadın
sabah güzellik imajı olabiliyor O
ukrayna-rusya falan bu durumu
destekleyen bir unsura Mesela Karadeniz
laz Roman şut kadını bölge oradan
geliyorsa onların genellikle sıfatı
olarak daha aşağıda bir istenmeyen
olarak tanımlandığını görüyoruz Bu da
yeterli değil mesleki olarak kadının
durumuna bakalım diyoruz kadınlar
romantik ilişkide bile erkeklerin
altında konumlandırılıyor yani siyah
erkek yönetim kurulu başkanı erkek sahip
erkek Onun altında kadın var ya da
mesleki olarak kadınların nasıl
gösterildiğine bakıyoruz orada şöyle
birşey karşımıza çıkıyor kadınlara
ilişkin Çok klişe meslek
bu tarz değil mi ona yaptığın
yakıştırıyor öğretmenlik asistanı
hemşirelik buralarda gösteriyor sanki
başka bir şansı yokmuş gibi aslında işte
homodios var homosapiyens var ya bir
başı kavramda hava Secret erir dünyada
kadının eve hapsedilmiş hali ve biz bunu
annelik yapısıyla evlilikle kapatıyoruz
eri dünyanın Evin İnsanları olarak
ortaçağdan beri böyle devam ediyor
kadının yeri evidir bir kadına ilişkin
değerler ATK ediyoruz mesela dedikodu
kıskançlık bilbet dizilerde kadına ait
erkekler ise daha cesurlar erkeğin
mafyası bile Cesur ve adalet peşinde
koşuyor
Ne bakıyorsunuz Peki bu tür imajları
adına sıralanırken rit ünyada reklam
tarafında Sanayi Bakanlığı altındaki
reklam Kurulu'na dair ne yapıyor diye
bakıyorsunuz orada trajik bir durum var
şöyle yapıyoruz Evet sigaranın üzerini
Kapatıyoruz Tamam ya da başka şeyler
yapıyoruz mesela Eğer dizide böyle
abartıp 5 saniyeden fazla öpüşüyor saiki
karşı cızbız diğeri zaten mümkün değil
Teknik olarak böyle bir şey yokmuş gibi
dünyada da mutlaka yasak sınıfına
sokuyoruz ama kadın istediğin kadar
bıçakla bilirsiniz bulabilirsin
patlatabilir simit al özle gelebilirsin
her şey serbest soğanlar da bir tarafta
etki yaratıyor sa diğer tarafta etki
yaratmadığını düşünüyoruz çok trajikomik
Ama bu sadece bu da değil bu mesela
Evet Ee öpüşmeyi sorun olarak gören
denetim kurulları öyleki yaşında bir
çocuğun bir ses yarışmasında büyütülmüş
haliyle ona uygun bir duruş postür
kıyafet olarak büyütülmüş makyaj olarak
bütün saliyle gösterilmesinde hiçbir
sakınca görmüyor bulaş problem yok öyle
görüyoruz Peki bunlar Hiçbir sonuç
yaratmıyor tedaviniz toplumda görmüyor
muyuz mesela pedofiliden bahsediyoruz
çocuk İsmail'den bahsediyoruz pedofil
Büyük ihtimal yapısal bir problem olarak
tanımlanıyor tam olarak sebebi
bulunabilmiş değil ama toplumdaki çocuk
istismarları sadece yüzde beşi pedofil
hastalarından kaynaklanıyor 195 kültürel
seçelim Yanarsın insanları kışkırtıyor
Uzo çocuğu o kostümü o duruşta bir moda
reklamında şöyle Duran işlemini etekli
tek parça 12 yaşında makyajlı bir çocuğu
bir burgas yoruz ve bu
bu incelikler derinlikler konusunda
hiçbir fikrimiz yok Bunları yasaklamak
bunları den etmek gibi derdimiz yok E
sonuçta ortaya çıkan şey şu oluyor
aslında şiddetin kendisini şişman
kendisini legalize ediyoruz sonra 20.
kattan şüpheli şekilde düşen Şule Çetin
davasında sanık babaya dönüp şunu
söylüyor kızına sahip çıksaydın ya da
Ankara'da tecavüz ettiği kadın otobüs
şoförleri dönüp şu şekilde sesleniyor
gecenin 11'inde kadının otobüste ne işi
var aslında mağdurları patik kurmamız
gerekiyor Ken sanıkla empati kurar
duruma geliyoruz Her şey normal
eleştiriyoruz kadını değersizleştirir
ötekileştiriyorsunuz ve
itibarsızlaştırma Uzel'in dünyada
başarısız olduğumuz çok açık bakın erkek
dünyasına başarısız olduğunu çok açık
doğaya baktığınızda tabiatta kadının
dişinin kurucu olduğunu görüyoruz Biz
siyaset ediyoruz ki hadi kadınlar daha
son değil aslında o zaman kadınları
siyasete soktuğumuzda kadın haline
sokuyoruz ki Tansu Çiller ne kadar kapı
özelliği gösteriyor hatırlayabilirsiniz
da söyleyeceğim veya
bu Meral Akşener Bence son derece
erkeksi tavırlar ile karşınızda sert
dikte eden doğrudan çok gibi kadın falan
gibi laflar yani kadını Bu meslek
gruplarına dahil ettiğimiz zaman kadın
haliyle görmek istemiyoruz onları bütün
bu Silsile Aslında korkunç sonuçlar
karşımıza çıkartıyor dünyanın heryerinde
kadına dair çocuğa dair hayvanları daha
şiddet var ama ülkeler toplumlar bunları
çözebilmek için çok başarılı çalışmalara
imza atılarak fakat biz tespit
noktasında zaten problemlerimiz var
söylediğim gibi yani bir şeyleri tespit
etmekten çok görülen görünmeyenler
kaynaklanır dedim Daha çok tepkisellik
leri yak sonra karşılaşıyoruz ruh
sağlığından insanların bile idğam-ı
kastrasyonu olağanüstü cezaları ya bugün
Instagram'da gördüm bir mesaj da şunu
söylüyor kendi kendini öldürmelerine
izin verelim diyor yani artık
yaratıcılığın hat safhasında çıkmış
durumdayız Aslında Bakın bu
o mesajları o kadar etkili mesajlar ki
bizim gibi eğitim düzeyi düşük
toplumlarda asla kitle iletişim
araçlarının tümünde ki tam etkinlik
durumunu bir kenarda bıraktık gibi
duruyor yani Kurtlar Vadisi hepinize
kalaşnikof alıp birini tanımıyorsunuz
gibi duruyor ama sıkça tekrarlanan
normal eleştirilen ve tekrar tekrar
karşımıza çıkan bu imajlar biliyorsunuz
Biz de gelişmiş bir öğrenme sistemi var
ayna nöronlar dediğimiz sistem öğrenme
sistemi ile Her şey bizim için çok doğal
ve yapılabilir hale geliyor ve
bu how sesine içerisinde bakın birkaç
tane örnek vereyim bunları ne kadar
ciddi düzeye ulaşabileceğini tüketimden
örnek vereceğim şimdi de ki daha az
ayetinde çocukların yüzlü 52'si metrosu
Çince bilhassa hallediyor işgaline
coğrafyasında isveçte çocukların Yedi
yaşına kadar çocukların 155'i büyükbaş
hayvanları lillah Renkli olarak görüyor
mil konusundan ya da dünyada milyarlarca
insanın katili kim kabul edilir biliyor
musunuz biraz dolaylama yapacağım ama
free God Elizabeth Taylor ya da John
gibi isimler Çünkü 1950 O ne yok
özgürlük gülüşlerinde kadın özgürlüğün
simgesi olarak elinde tutun mamülleri
tutuyorlardı ve yıllarca bu kampanya
devam etti Kapitalizm öyle bir süreç ki
seni hiç bırakmaz ne zaman ki Amerikan
Bu sigorta sistemi harcanan sigara
kaynaklı tütün Mamülleri kaynaklı
hastalıklardan
ve bütün Üzerine gelen yük verginin artı
1 doların üzerine çıktı sigara Türk
kakaolu yasaklayan bir eylem haline
geldi
ve bu Yapı içerisinde bu insanın geniş
öğrenme süreci Ayna nöronlar dediğimiz
süreç içerisinde bizim bu işe el atmadan
yürüyebilme şansımız yok yani sadece
Tabii ki medyadan bahsetme sadece
Reklamcılık diye bir de karşınıza sosyal
medya dedi Başka bir vaka geldi ve
kontrol edilemez Amerika'da kıta
avrupası'nda Önümüzdeki on yıl
içerisindeki en büyük ruh sağlığıyla
ilgili problemler olarak görünüyor
biliyor musunuz eşikteki çocuk diye bir
kavram Duydunuz mu hiç çivinin diye
geçiyor heçtekleri Ne bakarsanız pek çok
mesajı göreceksiniz bu çocuklar 10-12
yaşında özellikle kız çocuklarında daha
baskın instoş öyle çocuklar cinsel
kimliklerini çok erken kuruyorlar
tüketim pratiklerine bakıldığında dudak
parlatıcısı ndan tut bikiniye yani Bir
yetişkin kullanabileceği bütün
materyalleri kullanıyorlar ve Aslında bu
çocuklar eşikteki çocuklar ne çocuklar
ne yetişkinler arabalar ama ruh sağlığı
önü
Ben 10 yıldaki en büyük sorun olarak
tarif ediyorlar Biz bunu bile çok
uzağındayız' bunları tanımlamanın da çok
uzağındayız' Çünkü derin anlamı ile
ilgili gerçekten çok ciddi
problemlerimiz var bakın
Evet şunu söylemek gerekiyor Evet dönen
her şey görünmeyen dakika gülmeden
kaynakları üzerinden ve hiçbir şey de
göründüğü gibi de değildir aynı zamanda
biz bu anlamları tanımlayıp buna ilişkin
birtakım pratikler bütün sosyal
paydaşlarla geliştirme dediğim sürece
daha çok fazla Emine Bulut vakalarıyla
karşılaşacağız isimler değişecek ama bu
süreçler devam edecek
bu şöyle Yaşar Kemal'i açtım Yaşar Kemal
ile bitireyim Ama bu görünmekle ilgili
Bizim daha fazla görmekle ilgili benim
çok sevdiğim bir söz vardır romalıları
atfedilir Romalılar hayatını sanat
olarak görürler ve söyle derler daha
görülecek çok yer var daha görülecek çok
sevgi var daha okunacak çok kitap var
çünkü şu
Ya hayatım sanat uzun Hayat kısa derler
gerçekten bizim için de bu durum böyle
daha rahat atacağınız çok fazla sevgi
var Yeter ki bu idrak anlayışı
içerisinde olalım Yaşar Kemal'in O çok
sevdiğim sözünde de şöyle ifade eder bir
gün bir değil bulacağız var bu değil her
şeye Varan bu dil her şeyi
anlatabileceğimiz bu kadar özel biri
olacak ki biz insanlar dünyada der böyle
bölük pörçük parça parça dilsiz ve
düşmanca dolaşmaya cihazlar Umarım
tekrar Işıklar içerisinden olan
içerisinde yazsın diyorum Yaşar Kemal
haklıdır Çünkü gerçekten insan soyunun
geçtim artık ülkenin üzerine çıktım
devamı buna dayanıyor bu kadar
sevgisizlik içerisinde asabiye dediğimiz
toplumun parçalandık antlaşmanın hat
safada olduğu bir dünyada insan türüne
bir yer var gibi görünüyor arkadaşlar
inşallah
bu Sevgili üstadım söylediği gibi olur
[Alkış]
sevgiler